bonjour mesdames messieurs ici alexis ii
lancèrent tout d'abord en ce 27ème jour
de la campagne électorale fédérale de
toutes nouvelles données viennent d'être
publiées sur la situation financière du
gouvernement et denis ferland est donc
des données un peu plus positive sur le
bilan finalement des dernières années du
gouvernement conservateur plus possible
en tout cas
et qu'est ce que dit l'opposition ce qui
arrive c'est qu'on parle beaucoup du
déficit des prochaines années mais il ya
aussi un débat sur le déficit actuel
mais surtout du manque r10 contrairement
à ce que prévoit le dernier but joe
oliver pour l'année actuelle on est déjà
en déficit les chiffres ne semblent pas
leur donner raison après le premier
trimestre si ce sont les chiffres sont
publiés aujourd'hui
donc pour juin seulement le mois de juin
vous voyez que le surplus passe du même
mois de l'année 2014 à cette année d'un
point 5 1 milliards de dollars dont il
est un pur réduit mais regardez le
surplus du premier trimestre il augmente
de manière assez impressionnante de 400
millions $ à 5 milliards cette année
bon il ya là dedans une transaction qui
ne se reproduira pas un chiffre qui
n'est pas récurrent c'est la vente des
actions de gm ça ramène quand même à
autour de 3 milliards de drams surplus
pour les trois premiers mois vous
comprenez que avec la pression qui
assure monsieur racker de reconnaître
que tout ne va pas si bien qu'il qui le
prévoyait au moment du livreur ça réduit
cette fameuse pression et ça l'amène à
réagir ce qui n'est pas habituel non
plus parce que quand tu l'as vue
financier le publier à chaque mois on a
pas de réaction du gouvernement fédéral
mais on est en campagne électorale on
est bien conscient qu'il y en ait débat
et monsieur emprunt et c'est en italie
que dans le communiqué ça signifie que
nous faisons mieux que prévu avec notre
plan budgétaire ça lui permet en tout
cas de respirer un peu là en ce qui
concerne le débat sur le déficit de
cette année la situation les
prévisionnistes on pouvait voir d un
déficit plutôt qu'un surplus les
chiffres pour l'instant ne leur donne
pas raison les conservateurs qui
saisissent la balle au bond dans ce cas
la médaille est beaucoup été question de
ni des turbulences économiques actuelles
au cours de la semaine les libéraux ont
fait le choix de parler de leur bilan
dans les années 90 a fait deux fois en
une semaine qu'on amène pas le martin
sur la scène il était à toronto pour la
présentation de l'équipe économique même
exercice ce matin à montréal cette fois
avec une bonne partie de l'équipe
économique de monsieur trudeau monsieur
martin qui vient expliquer la en quoi
le choix de monsieur trudeau de stimuler
l'économie qui est à faire des déficits
est le bon il ne faut pas être obsédé
par l'élimination du déficit il faut
être conscient de la situation en
profiter notamment des bas taux
d'intérêt pour emprunter donc ils se
rappellent également ce que lui a faits
dans les années 90 vous allez voir
monsieur martin se rappeler et monsieur
mulcair être pas mal moins nostalgique
que lui on les entend tous les deux
lorsque nous avons pris pouvoir au début
des années 90 le canada qu'on a c'est le
pire déficit et le pire taux
d'endettement de tous les pays du g7
sont enfin il fallait agir rapidement et
ce c'est ça que nous avons fait nous
avons tracé un plan juge équitable ils
ne sont pas si à l'action pour nous
l'équilibré budgétaire n'était pas une
fin en soi c'est un moyen pour arriver à
nos fins celui qui a mis fin à tout
l'investissement fédéral en logement
social qui a coupé 24% des transferts
sociaux et les transferts en santé vers
les provinces qui à équilibrer le budget
sur le dos des provinces s'appelle paul
martin et quand on est à côté du roi de
l'austérité paul martin il faut se
garder une petite gêne avant de
critiquer la proche équilibrée du npd le
message de justin trudeau ce matin dhuys
et il revient là dessus le fait qu' il y
aura des déficits est un peu
inévitablement au train où vont les
choses lui va stimuler l'économie la
différence entre lui ses adversaires
c'est que lui ne reconnaît et les
prévoit l'équipement et joue la carte de
l'honnêteté du pragmatisme
on verra si ça va être payant à bien il
ya beaucoup de temps pour le constater
ici ou cinquantaine de journées aïe
si beaucoup d au revoir au revoir